- So, what was your favorite
Backstreet song growing up?
'Cause I could tell if you're a fan.
- No, I'm totally fine, everything's cool.
(Kelly chuckles)
I feel like, this is so crazy.
I feel like I'm sitting between
two tracks of a "Now that's
what I call music" CD.
(everyone laughing)
Like I just wanna take a minute and thank-
- [Kelly] We made it.
- [Taylor] I wanna thank
whoever books this show
for ignoring the discrepancy
between guests today.
(guests laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
This is incredible.
This is like the day you hop back
on the high school group chat.
Like, hey, I know I've ignored
everybody's baby shower invites,
but I have an update about what I'm doing.
(audience and guests laughing)
- [Brian] Oh my God.
- My favorite Backstreet voice song
was "Larger than life."
(crowd cheers)
- [Kelly] Larger than life.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
- That was in the game.
- That they got from two words.
- So that made me, yeah.
- Two words.
- [Taylor] I know I saw that on the card
and I was like.
- What?
- [Brian] All you go?
- [Kelly] Yeah. Whatever Brian.
(everyone laughs)
So Elyse, tell us about
your new comedy special,
you are hilarious and
you make me so happy.
So it's called Look At You, right?
- Yes, it is. Thank you.
(crowd applauds)
- [Kelly] You are so funny.
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Yeah, my new special: Look At You,
it's a lot about like mental health
and my own like mental health journey
as a basic white woman would say.
And.
(Kelly chuckles)
You know, there's dating
jokes and all that other stuff
but it's a lot to do with that,
and I talk about some very personal things
like losing my mom as a kid.
I promise, it's hilarious.
(crowd laughs)
And it's so funny,
'cause I talk so much
about like from that clip
I do so many jokes about therapy
and a lot are about my old therapist
that I don't see anymore,
but like my current therapist
and psychiatrist or the
Avengers as I call them.
(Kelly laughs)
Women who have saved my
life have both watched it
but they didn't like choose to watch it,
they were like, oh my
partner wanted to watch it.
So they watched it at
home with their partner
but couldn't tell their partner
that I was their client.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- Right.
- [Taylor] Because you know, laws.
(crowd and guests laugh)
And they were like, yeah, I just
I was sitting there watching it like,
oh, it's so weird, I can't tell them,
and I was like, oh man,
I feel like Tony Soprano.
(audience laughing)
I'm just like, you know what I do, okay.
- That's awesome, is it weird for them to,
'cause I have a therapist as well.
Is it weird for them to
watch your Comedy Special?
'Cause obviously a lot
of like comedians take
from like maybe dark
things that happen in life
and you turn them around
or you become relatable that way, like.
- Right.
- Is that weird?
- [Taylor] I don't know, I
mean, it's probably just weird
for them to see me in makeup, not crying.
(all laughing)
They're like you can't.
- [Kelly] And not a bum.
- [Taylor] Yeah, I mean the first time
I started seeing a therapist she was like,
don't worry, I'll never
google your Standup,
and I was like, please google it.
I want you to know like.
- [Kelly] So much Intel.
- Yeah, I'm keeping the lid on all this,
most of the time I'm like,
I would like you to see me put together
not just in a fetal
position in my home on zoom.
(all laughing)
So I'm like, no, see me at
my peak performance, please.
See me contoured for the love of God.
(all laughing)
But yeah, I assume it's
probably pretty weird.
There's a line in the special that I say
where I talk about being
diagnosed with bipolar
and I talk about how you
shouldn't be, you know
you shouldn't feel bad
if you get diagnosed
with mental illness cause
it's just information
about you that helps you know how
to take better care of yourself,
- [Kelly] Navigate yourself.
- [Taylor] And navigate yourself
which is something my psychiatrist said
to me and I totally stole
it, like it's my own idea.
Like I really should have given her credit
and instead I'm just on Netflix
like, and you know what,
it's just information about you
and everyone's like how wise?
And I'm like totally, I thought of it.
(crowd and guests laugh)
- And she can't say anything, 'cause laws.
- [Taylor] She can't say
anything, 'cause laws.
(all laughing)
- TM.
- 'Cause laws.
- I love that.